il y a un très beau proverbe israélien
qui dit tout ce que la vie te donne sans
effort elle te le reprend et ces gens
c'est ça c'est cette génération c'est ça
c'est-à-dire que ils sont devenus
célèbres riches ils ont tout eu ils
n'ont rien fait aucun effort pour ça
rien et ce film et il travaille pas il y
a pas d'études il y a rien et la vie se
venge toujours effectivement elle te le
reprend et là maintenant on commence à
avoir toutes les sanctions des réseaux
sociaux et ça tombe et elle pleure et je
suis triste pour elle cette jeune fille
mais même quand elle pleure elle se met
encore en scène pardon déjà je vais être
un petit peu méchant mais je pense que
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est pas
toujours les gens qui ont
enfin on va dire que
quand le plus de de de de culture de de
de d'éducation de machin de normalement
si tu étais éduqué un peu correctement
on t'apprend que tu fais des études tu
as ton bas tu as un petit boulot tout ça
et puis tu avances et puis tu grimpes
mais j'ai pas dit qu'il était idiot pas
du tout je dis juste aux gens voilà dans
la vie tout ce qui se fait rapidement
comme ça sans effort ça te pète à